this thing on hello I'm not sure that it
is actually now it says it's a time of
that hi welcome I'm Aaron Cohen I'm a
associate professor in the department of
medical informatics and clinical
epidemiology you are at if you don't
know one of our IDL industry leadership
talks the IDL is the informatics
discovery lab where we're trying to
create a entrepreneurial informatics
culture and establishing some
relationships with commercial entities
today I'm very pleased to introduce
Kaveri safavi who as both an MD and I
know in a law degree he's Accenture
health industry lead for North America
and for those of you don't know
Accenture is a global management
consulting and technology services and
outsourcing company that has a strong
focus on health care kahve oversees the
payer provider public health offerings
and is responsible for the health
strategy growth initiatives and market
capabilities of Accenture he joined
Accenture coming from Cisco in 2011
where he led the global health care
practice prior to that he's at thomson
reuters is the chief medical officer
right of health business and
unitedHealthcare's vice president of
medical affairs he's also served as
leadership roles at solution to Humana
healthspring and alexian hospital
network and he's going to talk about the
promise of healthcare IT moving beyond
electronic medical records which is
certainly a topic of interest to all of
us here so with that thank you erin and
good morning good afternoon it's nice to
be in portland I and I'm glad I got to
see a little fog and sun that tells me
it's definitely the Pacific Northwest I
live in Chicago I'm going to spend a
little bit of time talking about the
healthcare technology world after
electronic medical records most people
spend a lot of their time by the last
two decades when you said that
healthcare information technology is a
critical part of improving healthcare
and making healthcare better healthcare
information technology was equated to
electronic medical records and so all of
the energy was consumed around that and
one of the things that I think is
becoming abundantly clear is that there
is much more to information technology
than the electronic medical record and
some of its derivatives and so this is a
little bit about the post electronic
medical record world maybe that's not
post in the sense of it's not over but
everything else and where I come from on
this is really that you know technology
is means to an end but you have to put
it into context and you know one of the
first things that often happens is this
conversation about well Health Care's
very personal thing and technology tends
to be personalized and we have to be
really be careful about it and I stole a
quote from from Antoine they say exbury
he's a French you know pilot actually
and he's written a lot of interesting
books children's books but he was one of
the first he wrote this interesting
quote about whether or not technology
actually he personalizes things or makes
things even more personal and I want you
to remember that thought because I'm
going to draw a real distinction between
the concept of personalization and in
person which is something then health we
often talk about and the role of
technology can play so context i want to
lay before i talk about technology
specifically our fork are four themes
these are overlying themes that then
help me make sense of several specific
technologies the first one is the
concept of value in healthcare and one
of the real challenges we have is this
conversation about how much money we
spend and i'll actually say that i don't
think that the conversation is really do
we spend too much money but really are
we getting our money's worth because one
could argue that if we could eliminate
all of the things that we spend more
than we should and all the things we
spent less than we should how much we
spend might be about what we spend now
it might be more it might be less we
don't know but we feel a lot better
about it because we've eliminated all
the overs and unders and so I really
focus on this question of value and one
the places that we start to go to to
discover what people what what really
people want is when we start asking
people what they want from healthcare
and so this is an interesting study it's
a it's a couple of years old but it was
done on behalf actually a pharmaceutical
industry trying to understand what they
want and I make this point because the
way this question was asked we ask
patients in their own words how they
would define value and if you looked at
what how patients answers the question
about forty percent of patients said I
don't know but I know one thing it's not
cost and it's not outcomes and then
about a third set I have no idea a
little bit less than thirty percent said
cost four percent set outcomes and two
percent said cost and outcomes which is
interesting because from a public policy
perspective what we're trying to do is
communicate to our publics that they're
getting their money's worth by sharing
them information about costs and
outcomes which is fine except if you ask
people what they want almost two-thirds
say I have either I don't know or I know
it's not that stuff now that's an
oversimplified I concept and I want to
take it a little bit deeper but if you
ask doctors doctors would cost at the
top but then almost thirty percent said
neither cost nor outcomes as well sort
of like the patient's right so what does
that mean how do you make sense out of
that well here's how I make sense out of
it I look back at 50 years of sociologic
research and what people want from
health and you typically falls into two
buckets they want care and they want
compassion and care is often equated
with the biological part of health care
and then compassion tends to be
everything else and what we've often had
is this discourse about things like
customer service etc all those sorts of
things but what I think it really tells
us is not that people don't want
biological care but when you ask them
questions like this where they're making
relative comparisons they focus on the
things that they can actually judge and
the data will tell us that people
actually expect their care to be
technically correct and what they really
are judging on is all the other things
and an example I'll give you
outside of health care is the airline
industry I use this example a lot
because I think it's a really good
example if you got on a plane today and
you flew to Asia that plane would have
$1,000 seats on it five thousand dollar
seats and $10,000 seats coach business
first nobody on that plane has a
different expectation of arriving safely
right or on time you don't crash and
coach at a different rate than first
class would you pay ten thousand dollars
more for a totally different experience
and if somebody tried to launch a
carrier that would give you a
first-class experience lie flat seats
everything else like that with a coach
seat price thousand dollars and got you
there almost as safely as the other guy
there's no market for that once the
market has an expectation of a minimum
level of technical quality becomes very
hard for people to differentiate so when
you ask people questions like this
oftentimes what they're telling you is
I'm I was assuming that I was going to
get the best possible outcome so it's
hard for me to say that you know that's
pretty much what you're going to what I
expect from you for any level of payment
and all of the competition all the
differentiation actually goes on for all
the other things and that raises a
series of interesting questions that
we're going to talk about because
there's a very powerful role for
technology around all the other parts of
what makes health care a good experience
that we should will you know we'll talk
about you you'll get a sense of where
I'm coming from so this idea that value
is more than cost and value is more than
outcomes and value might have things to
do might have to do with things like
experience and trust and transparency
empowerment is really important the next
concept is what's going on economically
for the delivery system and this is very
important role for technology which is
pretty much the overarching economic
model that we're facing for providers is
that payment per unit of services going
down and or at least not going up and
that's really important because that
kind of cost pressure has huge
implications if you actually look at why
health care costs are going up this
couple of facts you should know one of
them is the rate of increase the rate of
increase year-over-year and you may or
may not know this but the rate of
is actually at a all-time low the last
three years healthcare has been
increasing at the slowest recorded rate
for the last 50 years now it's still
going up and if you actually look at why
it's going up there are two components
to white goes up one is we use more
stuff and the second is we pay more per
unit of stuff that we use prices are
going up well if you look at the
relative contribution of price of
service and quantity of service over the
last decade you see an interesting
phenomenon that stacked bar graph
represents year-over-year increase
between 2004 and 2008 the light blue
represents prices and then everything
else the red and the green represent
non-price demographic and utilization so
it's about 60 40 if you look out at 2010
2011 and 2009 what you see is that the
increase on a year-over-year basis was
somewhere around eighty to ninety
percent price and only ten to twenty
percent quantity so we've had this
really interesting phenomenon where the
last decade the primary driver of cost
increases has actually been prices of
services not quantity of services and
what's happening is that the marketplace
this is the regulatory marketplace in
the private sector is basically
discovered that has come to the
conclusion that one thing they have to
do to control costs is they have to
control prices people are going to get
paid less for what they do and if you
really want to take this down a level
you start to see things like this if you
look at why it is that US health care
cost is more expensive than the rest of
the world and you know that we pay we
spend twice as much on average per
person you start to look at findings
like this this is just hospital as a
component of total cost and in this
study period where we spent fifteen
percent of our gdp and the average of
all industrialized nations was nine
percent our rate of growth was about the
middle 4.4 were there right around the
average of everyone else but our per
capita spending on hospitals was was
about seventy percent more but it turns
out that it's not because we use more
hospital days in fact we were one of the
lowest consumers of hospital days of all
developed countries yet we spend more
than almost twice as much it's because
stuff
s'more if you look at utilization of
services you'll see a mixed bag but if
you look here's a routine office visit
routine office visit in the u.s.
eighty-nine dollars versus somewhere
between twenty and sixty dollars cost
per hospital stay 15,000 versus three or
four thousand dollars a couple of
interesting facts a physician in the
United States makes between five and ten
times an average American a physician in
the ten other European countries using a
comparator group is between two and
three times a citizen in their own
country so we have this huge disparity
and price the cost of inputs the
position incomes price of these days
these sorts of things all of this is
putting tremendous pressure on the cost
of production if you look at other parts
of our economy when you see this kind of
pressure that's usually when technology
starts to get used to extract large
amounts of costs out of the system
typically in the form of substituting
for labor creating models where you
start the shift work to your customer
these are all areas where technology is
going to play so when the delivery
system is faced with this reality that
they're going to be required to deliver
more services to more people and require
more expensive inputs but not getting
any more money for it then technology
has to be brought in in order to try to
solve for that problem and that's not
just a you know that's not a clinical
outcomes conversation that's a real
structural input kind of a conversation
the next big trend that's interesting in
this area is this concept of
demographics and it's a really important
to understand this because the
generational issues that are going on
now have a big impact on information
technology and you probably know this
but excuse me one of the really
interesting facts is that if you look at
the attitudes towards technology and
healthcare you find that the baby
boomers think about the world a lot more
like their parents than their children
and so we've got basically four
generations of caregivers for
generations of patients we have three
generations of caregivers you've got the
sort of the traditionalists are the
post-world war two then you
the baby boomers then you have the Gen X
and the Millennials we actually have now
Millennials entering into the workforce
and they think about things in these
generations very differently now most of
leadership comes out of the baby boom
generation but there are some very
marked differences and I'll give you a
simple example in the world of
technology that people in this room will
understand but I do a lot of speaking to
boards and operating leaders and I this
example comes up all the time email to
emails interesting technology because if
you survey the use of email under the
age of 20 what you discover is it's
almost never used it's actually used by
people under 24 two primary reasons to
talk to their parents and to engage in
formal communication and yet email
dominates the working landscape so the
medic right now about twenty percent of
all position practices use email to
communicate with their patients and
there are all kinds of conversations
going on around how do we make email
more useful and available for doctors to
talk with their patients now this is a
real example but think about what's
happening in a few years physician
practices are going to be recruiting
young physicians into their practice and
they're going to say I got great news
you can email your patients to
physicians who've never actually used
email as a primary form of communication
now that distinction is an interesting
one because those of you who are
understanding what i'm talking about
would say well you're under 20 use
social software and social software has
email attributes built into it so maybe
that's not really the right distinction
the big difference for people in this
room who don't typically use social
software to engage in communication
between that and email is social
software allows you the opportunity to
have people you know relate to other
people you know without you making the
choice about how you want to inter
mediate it right so in an email I like
I'm an email person I'm not a social
software person my buddies that I went
to college with that we graduated 30
years ago they send me a funny joke or a
picture I have to decide who I'm going
to send it to but my kids somebody post
something and everybody else who's a
friend gets to see it without that
person having to make a death this
about how they want to move that
information now you think about a
medical practice and you think about
that difference between a pure email
versus some kind of a social platform
for a conversation suddenly patients
might be able to share information
experiences with other patients which is
right now going on anyway but now the
physicians practice actually becomes a
source of that kind of intermediation so
this is a very very important area now
what we've learned is that you it's very
very hard for people who don't use these
technologies to incorporate them into
their operating model so that some of
you guys are familiar with this
terminology of digital immigrant and
digital native I'm a digital immigrant
basically the baby boomers are all
digital immigrants we grew up in a
pre-digital world and we've learned
about this later on I worked for Cisco
which is a company that says it was
there at the beginning of the internet
networking company our leadership at the
time were largely baby boomers and our
CEO said we do not have enough digital
natives on our own leadership team to
understand what our markets want from us
the argument they're making is that
business leaders actually have to go out
of their way to bring people not from
their demographic into positions of
leadership for the purposes of
understanding this technology and in
health here's an example you'll see a
lot of this what we want to communicate
with our 70 or 80 year old patient well
you say well they don't use technology
to communicate that's great but who's
their caregiver might be a 25 year old
granddaughter so it's not the patient
it's the patient support system that you
need to understand their technology
preferences similarly when you ask these
people what's important to them they
answer the questions differently so if
you're over 46 and the question is
what's the most important factor in
selecting a hospital you'll put
physician direction at the top followed
by reputation followed by prior
experience but if you're under 46
reputation actually floats to the top
not surprising whereas position
direction is is down at number three so
the relative role of what your friends
think which is enabled by technology is
fairly critical
the last contextual point I want to make
before we start talking about
technologies is this concept of
financial incentives so we're very much
focused on this idea that in health we
have this third party in direct payment
model and if we just created the right
financial incentives good things would
happen interestingly enough while health
is trying to figure out how to engineer
financial incentives the rest of
economics has discovered behavioral
sciences and behavioral economics and
realize that money alone isn't enough to
create choices that people want to make
and there's some studies that are
starting to appear right now in that
literature around healthcare which
really illustrate how far we have to go
and it also shows you where the can
begin to see where technology might play
a role so one of the concepts is if we
just got people to pay enough money in
terms of a co-payment or coinsurance
they would make choices that we want an
example is choosing cost-effective
doctors so this is a bit this is an
interesting study that comes out of
Massachusetts it's a survey and a
simulation and what they did was they
wanted to figure out what would happen
how do people make choices about going
to a high cost or low-cost network so in
this example there was the preferred
network of doctors where the patient had
a fifteen dollar copay if they went then
there was the non preferred network
where the patient had a fifty-dollar
copay if they went and the first example
was well if you know nothing except a
fifteen dollar a fifteen dollar network
and a fifty-dollar network how would you
sort turns out eighty-nine percent of
the people would go to the 15-dollar
networks of the low out of pocket and
the rest would go to the high
out-of-pocket now if a friend or family
member told them that they should go to
the more expensive network 89 goes down
to 45 and if a doctor told them they
should go to the more expensive network
89 goes down to 24 so huge drop-offs
then the next question they asked is how
much money would one have to spend to
overcome the recommendation of a friend
or family member or a doctor and it
turns out that you'd have to spend two
hundred and ninety dollars to overcome
the recommendation of a friend or family
there's only a $35 spread
copay and you'd have to spend about four
hundred and forty dollars out of your
pocket to overcome the recommendation of
a doctor these are in excess of what the
total visit costs so to simply tell
people to create financial incentives
and to ignore the fact that these kind
of factors are driving decisions means
we are we're really missing what the
rest of our experience in life about
decision making and the role of money is
in fact there was an interesting study
done on drugs and drug discharged from a
hospital there's a lot of effort to try
to get people to take their drugs when
they go home and what they discovered
was even if you take a drug you go into
the hospital for a heart attack you're
discharged with medications and they and
you make the drugs free less than half
of the people will take the drugs for
the condition they were just
hospitalized from even when the drug is
free this is really interesting
statement because that's exactly why
they came to the hospital for so it's
not so simple as money now take that
context and start thinking about well
what is the role of historically the
role of technology bin and way I think
about it is we've really focused on it
to me health care we at this point we
really understand that it's a series of
interactions between people and other
entities people and other people people
and resources people and information and
all of the electronic health record and
all of that the emphasis on healthcare
IT has been focused on the relationship
between people and information and we
haven't really thought as much about the
role of Technology in these other areas
and what we're starting to see now is
all of the influx of interest in the
role of technology and enabling all of
these other pieces in fact there's this
a whole bunch of interesting
conversations going on including the
relative role of ten technology
substitute for people or as technologies
just simply there to enable people in
order to do their natural thing you know
can you actually replace a human or a
doctor or is always about augmenting
them and this is a very interesting
debate going on across lots of sectors
in terms of the relative role of
technology and we can talk a little bit
about that later on if you want
but I want to focus on three technology
trends outside of the electronic medical
record that I think are going to have an
impact on these health care problems i
just described and will take them to
whatever extent you want to take them
and i'll go through them and then we can
go back and have a conversation about so
i want to talk about the three tens then
I want to talk specifically about two
trends and their health care expression
one or one of them is this concept of
virtual health used to be called
telehealth called carrot a distance and
the second one is social technology and
social networks and its relative role
and where where some of the
possibilities exist so the three big
trends are big personal social that's
kind of how I think about it where's
technology going and I basically say the
technology in general is becoming big
personal and social and I want to trick
them a little bit into what they might
mean in terms of health so big to me is
interesting because you know we're all
used to the abundance of data that's
going to get created I just put a
statistic up here for the illustration
2015 will produce what that year will
produce data equal to 120 thousand times
the total of all written words for all
recorded history there will be three IP
addresses per person on the face of the
earth by that year which is think about
that that's a profound number three IP
enabled devices are dresses per person
but what's really interesting about this
is that when we think about big there's
been this whole emphasis on big data
being about large amounts of data but
what other industries have realized is
that the power isn't necessarily simply
in quantity it's actually in making
sense of disparate information and where
industries have actually started to like
retail and financial services have
started to really do interesting work is
by taking data for example data from
your buying behavior and intersecting it
with other data like data from social
sentiment or data from other sources and
in health we keep thinking about big as
more of the same and haven't really
necessarily mentally crossed the rubicon
that big data might not be about taking
a little bit of EMR
data to a lot of EMR data but actually
contrast that with taking EMR data and
combining with something else some
completely different form of information
that could range from self-reported data
external financial data social sentiment
data all these sorts of things the to it
I want to spend more time on our
personal and social so let's talk about
personal for a second personal is an
interesting concept because personal is
actually something more than just mobile
even though I use a mobile statistic
here to illustrate a point which is that
if you follow the trends for television
mobile excuse me watching television on
your cell phone you remember about eight
or nine years ago there was a big
movement to something called mobile TV
and the idea was that you could watch TV
on your cell phone and that actually
disappeared and it got replaced with
what the cable company is now referred
to as TV anywhere because what they
realized was that people didn't want to
watch TV on their cell phone what people
wanted to do is they wanted to watch
their TV content wherever they were at
on their own terms if the only device
they happened to have was their cell
phone that's great but the minute they
walked into a room and they had a bigger
screen or they had a pad they wanted it
on that screen and what happened was
with healthcare was that we started to
get focused on the cellular phone as a
device and lost sight of the fact that
the issue wasn't on that form factor the
issue was that people want to consume
information on their own terms wherever
they're at and so what's happening is
there's a series of technologies flowing
in and the primary objective or the
primary need is that people want to
consume information that's specific and
unique to them on their own terms part
of it might be physically where they're
at so Mobile is an example but there are
other issues here like the context
concept of context awareness do people
here understand what the concept of
context awareness is and technology have
you heard of this term a few people so
context awareness is basically
technology that's adapted to knowing who
you are and personalized to your
circumstances so if any of you have
used have any of you use the couponing
technology called shop kicks or an
equivalent of it shop kicks is something
my teenage kids taught me about it
delivers to your cell phone the coupon
of the day for the store you happen to
be standing in at that time now how does
it know that well it knows a bunch of
things first of all you sign up for it
so it knows something about your
preferences but how does it know when
you're in a mall that you're in victoria
secrets and you're not in abercrombie
because it can't tell from Wi-Fi
location that's two too close they
actually figured out that you can emit
out of the PA system of a store a
inaudible frequency sound that your
smartphone's speaker can detect that is
registered to the store you're in and
localize you to being in that registered
retailer so it says ok I know you like
victoria secrets because that you use to
buy their I know you're standing in
victoria secrets in this mall at this
given time I'm going to deliver to you
the specific coupon of the day for that
store right there when you're ready to
check out if you buy a thick Gucci bag
or any other product right now there is
a small chip inside of it and if you
walk into a Gucci retailer it knows what
you bought and when you bought it and
will change the visual displays to
reflect what's interesting to you based
on your buying patterns so this context
of this notion of context awareness is
very powerful because in health we think
about information basically we tell
people go search the table of context
and find what you want right as opposed
to I know who you are I know where
you've been I know what you're
interested in I'm just going to shoot to
you the information that's important to
you at that point in time to make a
decision so personalization is very
interesting concept another concept
behind personalization is this concept
of augmentation augmentation is this
idea of taking what is essentially a
currently a physical experience and
superimposing information on it to make
it more interesting to you
and to change its appeal so sports on
television sports on television started
in the 50s as grainy black-and-white and
it was kind of an interesting
alternative but you know no one would
ever think about watching a game on
television if you could go to the game
and then technology moved along and we
started to add higher better quality
imaging then we started to add instant
replay than we started to add scores and
by the 90s there was a whole discussion
about whether it was better to go to a
game or watch the game on television
right you probably remember that we had
suddenly demonstrated there is the first
order of distinction between a in person
experience and a personal experience and
the stadiums had to respond by bringing
the screens and the information into the
stadium if you couldn't get the
information that you could see on TV you
wouldn't go to the game now here's a
point I'm making here's the point I make
with respect to health care we have this
concept that the highest order of a
personal health care experience is one
that is delivered by a person in person
that's the gold standard for service I
would argue that if we just follow our
experiences in other parts of our lives
there is a big difference between a
personal experience and an in-person
experience and what we should real what
people really want is a personal
experience not to be confused with an
in-person experience and it's a high
reliance on technology so the concept of
augmenting your physical experience with
information might actually create
something more personal and I want I'm
going to give you a real living example
of that on what's going on in telehealth
right now as a way to show you that
telehealth is an interesting
intersection where we might actually
create a more personal experience even
though we separate the doctor and the
patient physically and they're not
physically in person another area that's
interesting in the world of personal
information is the fact that we've moved
to this highly visual environment visual
information where people can see things
there's a lot of interesting data that
says that when people see something as
opposed to read it they retain it they
they think about things differently
discharge instructions for example with
a video given by a person are very
different than discharge instructions
that have to be read or that someone has
to read and so people are beginning to
understand that visual information is a
very powerful form of communication that
can be customized to the way you receive
information and that's becoming a very
big part of how people are communicating
the last big trend is this concept of
social and here's a really interesting
and important thing when we think about
social we think about things like
facebook facebook is fine facebook is a
great form of social interaction but
what's really going on here is it starts
with the assumption that all humans are
naturally social they've always been and
technology is a way to allow people to
extend their natural social tendencies
beyond the ability to have beyond their
physical encounters so what at Facebook
really do Facebook began to solve for
the kind of things that people did in
their own communities square but you
weren't constrained to the people that
you happen to be living in the
neighborhood with everybody that you
could that you had some commonality with
some common interest with met you could
begin to have an interaction with the
technology really just allowed our
natural human social instincts to be
delivered on a very large scale and it
started with simple things like the
sense of community but now you're
beginning to see people use social
platforms to do things like allow users
to create their own content which is a
very interesting and important area and
we'll talk a little bit about that
self-service this is a really critical
area technologies that are used for
people to serve themselves started out
in for example the this got a real big
lift after the natural disaster starting
with the tsunami in Phuket and then the
Hurricanes in Haiti that basically
rescuers were putting up various kinds
of websites where victims were able to
match themselves with people who were
looking for them completely outside of
the role of the government basically
survivors and people who are out there
trying to deal with the recovery
on their own and it's become a very
important part of how governments are
actually starting to think about how
they can serve their communities they
basic argument is this people need more
services and we can provide rather than
us providing services we provide
technology and then people go take care
of themselves and I'll give you an
example of that in a second and the last
and and the interesting point here on
games is people have recognized that
humans like to play games and so you can
take advantage of that with a social
platform and you can begin to engage in
these kind of gaming behaviors and
here's a interesting example I put over
here well you can see the list people
have talked about what is gaming do
there's a whole hypothesis around kids
who play games have make for example
faster decision-making and speedier
thinking there are actually surgical
residences now that are starting to
either look for surgeons that are gamers
or train them to be gamers because they
think they actually manipulate the the
technology the laparoscopic technology
better they can multitask better they
have better visual processing it's
actually fascinating there was an
interesting study published around
children that said that if you have a
choice between a child playing a game
and watching television you want them to
be gamers because they that's an active
skill that actually teaches them a
series of tasks versus watching
television which was a totally passive
skill this thing called stick was
actually built to help people meet their
health goals and actually a whole bunch
of other goals and it's a really
fascinating concept it's basically takes
advantage of the fact that people like
to compete with themselves but they need
a platform for it what they actually
what's the guys that stick learned I was
talking to the founder about this was
people need an incentive and so let's
pick something like weight loss so the
traditional way of I'm going to lose
weight typically doesn't work then the
next question is well who do you have to
compete with in order to lose weight and
they said well I'm going to set up this
model where I can nominate I can create
a reward system where if I lose a
certain amount of weight I get a reward
back and it might be a financial reward
it might be some other points and they
said well that kind of works but it
doesn't really work you need a referee
so they allowed you to introduce a
concept of a referee said so
I have to ask Aaron and Aaron has to
validate that I lost weight and if Aaron
validates that I lost weight then I get
my reward and what they found was what
people really wanted to compete with
what really made a difference was they
developed this concept called the anti
charity the anti charity is the
following people were most motivated to
stick to their goals if failing their
goals resulted in reward for something
they hate a lot so people actually said
like if I pick pick pick a charity pick
a cause I hate if I lose I register my
credit card and if I don't lose weight
and Erin doesn't say that I didn't I met
my weight goal then money leaves my bank
account and goes to the charity I hate
the most and they found that people
actually lost weight when they use this
technology to game themselves into doing
those sorts of things but i think is
fascinating that people would actually
volunteer to do that it's really
fascinating so let's talk about
telehealth for a second as a specific
example of these technologies and this
is a really interesting one because i
think it's worth it's worth
understanding where this is going
there's a lot of interest by investors
and entrepreneurs venture capital do you
read venture capitals current investment
thesis tell help is one of their top
areas for investment technology
investment and why is that it's not
because we're trying to solve the
problem of the people in rural Alaska or
the Indian Reservation the concept of
using technology to sell for people who
are unserved or underserved as
interesting but it's a relatively narrow
opportunity what's really going on as a
recognition that technologies like
virtual care actually create an
alternative for the already served and
potentially create a superior care model
for the already served now how does it
that you how is it that you can take a
normal doctor patient relationship that
works today and suggests that i can
introduce telehealth into that
environment and actually create a better
experience than the already served
experience well in order to do that you
have to meet certain thresholds the
first thing you have to do is the
technology has to be at least good
enough and what happened was people
started taking high definition immersive
technologies from business conferencing
and bringing it starting to apply
and telehealth and what they realize is
if the technology is is good enough in
terms of its audio visual capabilities
you can begin to register levels of
satisfaction with a virtual encounter
that are in the ninety percent
satisfaction and willingness to
recommend now normally a physician live
physician and encounter will register in
the 90s but traditional telehealth
technologies registered in the 60s so
getting the technology good enough for
people to say willing to recommend in
the 90s is just get you to parity but
getting to parody wasn't going to be
good enough what you actually had to say
was what can the technology do that can
never be accomplished in a traditional
face-to-face visit no matter how hard we
try and what people started to do is
realize well there's a couple of things
that you can do that are not possible
you can have one too many you can have
one patient and many doctors so for
example and people are starting to build
these kind of business models you go in
to see a doctor and the doctor consults
with another doctor while you're in the
room as opposed to you having to go out
and seek the second doctor in the normal
sequential model and another example is
if you have cancer today if you're lucky
enough to go to a cancer center that is
that uses this method method then some
of those patients may get a
collaborative conference to plan out
their treatment and that is in many ways
consider the gold standard for cancer
treatment but in most cases you don't
get that opportunity right because it's
too hard to convene the doctors much
less the doctor and the patient so you
pretty much get the recommendation of
the person that you're in front of well
technology lowers the cost of convening
and makes it perfectly possible for
people to get the advantage of group
collaboration and a group decision
making in a way that wasn't possible and
you're starting to see in the US and
outside of the US these ideas of well
why don't we give every single patient a
collaborative visit where all the
experts are lined up we go over their
case you know we can do that with
technology technology lowers the cost of
convening so you see those kinds of
things but the thing that's really
interesting is this issue of
augmentation so some work that has been
done on telehealth stumbled into this
actually somewhat by accident what they
did was they
started they did examples where a
patient would come in and see the doctor
and the doctor was using remote
diagnostic equipment so an electronic
otis scope to look in the patient's ear
and what they decided was well let's let
the patient see the same eardrum the
doctors looking at normally when you go
to see a doctor he puts a scope in you
don't know what the doctor is saying
well in this electronic Oda scope world
the patient on that the doctor was
looking at the patient's ear drum they
just showed an image of the patient's
ear drum back to the patient so he could
see their own or she could see their own
eardrum or heart sounds the patient can
you can hear the heart sounds on the
same electronic stethoscope as the
doctor can hear in Scotland when they
first did this they actually were taking
patients into an emergency room and they
were doing different trials including
giving the patient both a virtual and an
in-person visit and they were asking the
patient's how they like them and they
were getting a very consistent subset of
patients that were reporting that they
actually like the virtual visit visit
better than the face-to-face visit when
given both options when experiencing
both options and the reason they said
they liked the virtual better was
actually two of them one of them is they
actually thought the doctor paid more
attention to them now this is probably
an artifact of what happens when you
have a screen as the method for an inner
counter there's this natural sense of
focus and whereas in an exam room
there's a lot of ambient distractions
and when the doctor standing up and has
the hand on the door there's a
tremendous amount of distraction because
they actually timed it and found that
the doctors were paying the same amount
of time attention but the patients were
registering a different perception of
attention the second is the patient said
that they they loved seeing their
eardrum and seeing their heart sounds
they'd never seen that before and that
made the visit much better so here's an
example of where augmenting the visit
with information like the biologic and
few of your own body was far more
important than having a doctor in the
room with you and if you start thinking
about how this might play itself out in
a disruptive fashion you could have a
delivery system that does things the
old-fashioned way and then you could
have a delivery system that decides that
they want to go into a geography but
rather than necessarily building all of
the physical capacity and putting the
doctors there they're going to make the
investment and tell
health technology where they have some
of this remote equipment and they
compete with the physical world by
offering up this world where you get
this new enhanced visit and the promise
is well you know you can you can see
your own eardrum and you can hear your
own heart sounds all those sorts of
things you might begin to see a real
interesting competitive differentiation
now what would happen is that the local
market might respond by saying you know
what I'll just buy that technology and
use it myself now what's better now it's
me in the room plus the technology and
that might work but they might also
discover they don't need to be in the
same room as the patient that's not
really what the issue was the issue was
the personalization this is one of those
areas where you start to think about the
distinction between the two for those of
you who might be familiar with the robot
the robotic surgery The Da Vinci robot
the value proposition around the da
Vinci robot was originally this idea of
doctor specialty position in one
location patient in another location and
then the second order benefit was
supposed to be that the technology
basically compensated for motor issues
like it fixed up down right left and it
fixed hand tremor and so you've got a
better clinical result but I've actually
spent some time talking to the guys who
were some of the original investigators
and they said that that the actual
revolution of the robot hasn't been
recognized yet the real revolution is
going to come when people recognize that
when you take a physical interaction of
surgery and you put a digital pathway
you can now introduce information in and
augment the surgeons hands with tumor
markers with imaging information and
that's a that's a different surgery than
the surgery that's performed by physical
direct contact so the idea of going from
a physical platform to a digital
platform allows one to augment the
physical experience with information and
that's where we start to begin thinking
about well how do these technologies
work they actually start to work by
creating a totally different experience
so let's go back to that first slide
that I showed you where the study of you
know value right what do people want
well we don't know because we haven't
pressed the envelope but the ability to
augment and the really the ability to
show a different value might actually
come when you start to use technologies
to create this platform for these kind
of augmented experi
Frances the last example is the concept
of social platform so I started touching
on them but I'm going to give you a few
specific examples one of them is this
concept of using a social platform for
patients to create their own content
through their own learning this is a
really interesting and important study
and that it illustrates the power of it
so patients like me some of you might be
familiar with it it's a web site's been
around for probably eight nine years it
was created by an entrepreneur based on
his own family conditions to allow
patients with serious clinical and
illnesses to find other patients with
similarly serious clinical conditions on
the theory that nobody knows what i'm
going through better than me or people
like me my doctor my nurse can't explain
what it's like to have my condition they
can't explain to me what the side
effects really feel like and that
business model worked out fine then they
found a very interesting accidental
finding that really shows the power of
the social platform and it was published
a few years ago as the first ever
patient self-organized clinical trial
ever published in a peer-reviewed
journal and it basically worked like
this the patients who had this
particular disease neurologic disease
ALS had been using lithium which is a
drug for bipolar depression off-label
for a while because there was this
concept that somehow it improved your
cognitive capacity the problem with
lithium is it's very dangerous so
there's a very narrow therapeutic window
between toxic and effective and what
happened was that there was the chatter
on patients like me about does it work
or doesn't work does it not work and
they decided they were going to organize
their own trial literally so some
patient nominated up an Excel
spreadsheet they created a symptom list
and people report it did I take lithium
and did it work did it not work and
patience in real time watched what other
patients were saying and it's the
investigators then looked at the
patients like me data for off-label
lithium and they tracked it and they
found that when the windows when the
site first made this information
available the use of off-label lithium
got really high and then patients
started discovering the drug didn't work
like they expected to off-label and the
patients like me community basically
self extinguished
lithium is an off-label drug in their
own community with zero intervention by
any doctor or drug company that is a
complete self organized practice and
that's a what that tells us is that in
health as we're trying to figure out new
and innovative models including models
that might be lower cost you could this
this concept of making platforms
available for people to start solving
their own problems begins to get
surfaced in a way that we haven't
thought about at all and as opposed to
everything being curated by the medical
community and you know I touched on this
concept of municipal governments many
government many city governments now
have things like traffic and pothole
finding trap pothole finding software
some of you may be familiar with this
right where you report that you found a
pothole it saves the it saves the
government money because they don't have
to drive around and document it it also
means they can fix them faster and
fixing them faster isn't just a nice
thing for votes actually in many
municipalities the city has liability
for the damage to a vehicle of an
unrepaired pothole so it's actually a
risk management think the faster they
get the pothole fixed the less they pay
in insurance claims so it's it's a it's
a concept that says let the technology
have the people do their own work well
and health we haven't really thought
about that yet but this idea of moving
work to your customer which is happening
right now in Airlines and hotel Inge and
banking there's a huge opportunity for
help to do that and think about what
that means there's actually two benefits
to that one of them is some of the costs
when you shift some of the costs back to
your customer it lowers your cost of
production and remember we have a
challenge right now which is we have to
figure out how to lower our cost of
production so you do what other
industries do you give some of the work
to your customer but there's actually a
second benefit what people have learned
is that that consumers customers people
actually feel more ownership and more
engagement when they do some of the work
themselves it's not just about shifting
the work it's actually about creating a
different level of engagement if the
sort of best
described example of this is the Betty
Crocker cake box cake mix and some of
you may know this story because it's
been written about before I do people
know the story so so you have to put an
egg in when you do the Betty Crocker box
mix right but not because you have to do
that they actually they can make the Box
find with all the content they
discovered that when they took that
content out if you added the egg you
felt like you bake the cake it's
completely about this perception of
participation and ownership in the cake
so so people are starting to say well
wait a second why don't we start
thinking about technology to shift some
of the work back to our customers partly
to get the work off of us and partly to
make them feel like they're part of the
process and make them feel more engaged
and you can see in health how that could
very naturally be a useful tool so the
concept of using social technology and
social platforms to get at all of these
layers is hanging out there and I think
you're going to begin to see people
working on that the last concept around
social technology is that there's
actually evidence that at least some
clinical conditions have a literal
social component to them and there's a
concept called social contagion that's
been documented for a few diseases I
just put this up here to illustrate how
far this social thing goes so Nicholas
Christakis is a physician and
sociologist at Harvard he's a
well-regarded expert on social networks
and clinical disease 2007 he published
the article in New England Journal of
Medicine about obesity and basically the
study was something like this the
probability of a person being obese is
related directly related or most
strongly related to whether their friend
or their friends friend is obese
regardless of the geographic proximity
of the two people and the fact that
people next to you or in your community
or obese confers almost no risk so he
actually lists these risk factors from
this study so it's almost a two hundred
percent chance if you have a mutual
friend who's obese your risk of being
obese goes up by two hundred percent
your risk of being obese if your spouse
is obese is actually less than
one-fourth the risk of a mutual friend
that's got all kinds of stuff behind
that there probably for a different
conversation and an immediate neighbor
has essentially no risk
so he makes this point because he says
we're trying to figure out how to solve
for obesity you know it's one thing to
focus on you know food in the cafeteria
but it's another thing to understand
what the friend patterns are and in fact
if we could map them we could consider
how we might want to somehow participate
intervene engage the social
relationships the technology and the
information allows us to create a map of
social relationships and think about how
we may want to engage so it's not just
you know everything we all these layers
live underneath this idea of if we could
understand humans social behaviors and
somehow measure in it and intervene
there's lots to be done so let me end
with this quote from 1830 for that
device over there is the precursor it's
actually the net Linux that the scope
and it's roughly in the same form it is
today except that instead of a single
piece that goes into one ear there is
too soft flexible rubber pieces that go
into both ears and this is what they
wrote about the Linux that the scope in
1834 that will ever come into general
use notwithstanding its value is
extremely doubtful because it's
beneficial application requires much
time and gives a good bit of trouble
both of the patient and the practitioner
because it's human character are foreign
and opposed to all of our habits and
associations so some of the stuff that I
said that you might pretty much fit
right into that right and these look at
it said that stuff is never going to
work it might make sense but remember
you go back 170 years and that's pretty
much what they said about the
stethoscope which we're still using
today so thank you I've got a few
minutes I'll be happy to take any
questions if you have any and thank you
for having me here I appreciate that's
my contact information my email if
anybody wants to email see notice
generations and get that right so just
remember to push the button when you ask
questions so I can be recorded anybody
have any questions or no question go
ahead
that's okay Johnny Boychuk um so my
question is you know the telemedicine
concepts that you laid out the
collaborative case conferences or
collaborative patient visit conceptually
or academically makes a ton of sense
from a workflow standpoint completely
flies in the face of how practices are
structured if so is anyone doing it
right so a really important question and
why it hasn't part of the reason it
hasn't taken off as people are trying to
incrementally layer in the existing
workflow what you're beginning the
businesses that have become successful
are the ones that have basically tried
to build for all intents and purposes
built for purpose telemedicine workflows
because if you try to do it it's very
hard to commingle it in the existing
example so the so give you an example
right now the two the two telemedicine
companies that have acquired the most
venture capital money in the last three
years both focus on think of them as
they compete largely with urgent care
and physicians are American well in
teladoc and their basic concepts are
people who are traveling or at home and
can either md live as the third one
actually they can there's it basically
brokers doctors who have free time with
patients who want to be able to have a
conversation with that doctor and
creates an economic model that makes it
work for everybody because the only way
for this to work is for doctors who have
dedicated themselves to a delivery
system that works this way and the
technology allows a little bit of load
balancing so the doctors can say I'm
going to be available between three and
eight and so put me on call for those
three hours but what we found is if you
don't build a delivery system that
actually contemplates this it's almost
impossible to do anything other than add
cost Kevin
patient telemedicine anymore now we've
got virtual nurses showing up that
people are actually starting to try
where you won't even have a person go
into the room and that actually raises a
really interesting conceptual question
for and it's on many orders of magnitude
one of them is that for telemedicine to
really be effective it has to change the
economics of labor if you actually look
at the long-term total cost of
telemedicine technology if you take a
doctor of an impatient and all you do is
separate them by space but everything
else is the same it doesn't actually
affect the cost very much so you have to
begin to think about what you can do
either by using one too many so you're
scaling resources are beginning to use
technology to do some of the work on its
own to have an impact so a lot of those
things I think are the beauty of the
telehealth is it's it's a it's a
mechanism for beginning to add these
other kinds of things that effectively
have labor costs reduction however the
counterpoint to that is this very
significant debate about whether one can
actually ever replace clinical judgment
in any meaningful way and so how far
these technologies can go I think what
it's going to happen is the marketplace
is basically allowing us to take what is
now a very monolithic model so no matter
how simple or complicated your problem
is your choices are go to a doctor and
create a whole array of options for
those that you need to go to what dr.
you go to a doctor for those that you
can go to a doctor or group that's
different and for those that can be
served by technology and some kind of
self-service great I think what really
technology does is it creates us allows
us to unpack this relatively expensive
delivery model and allow lower-cost ones
to come in but never to replace those
things for which and in person
face-to-face visit is necessary you know
if you have a complex condition where
you might be life-threatening and
someone's going to do something you
probably don't have an alternative other
to physically go in the room and be with
that person and nobody suggesting that
that's ever going to go away so it's
really about array of choices do you
think it would ever be possible for
technology to enable context-sensitive
teams to assemble on the spot for a
given
because that's probably I mean the point
would be that if everyone num if you
knew something about what the person
needed at least probably by some formula
or some algorithm that challenge would
be that mean you kind of people are
already experimenting with that right
now in that there are it's not in there
have been experiments done like this
there's not like a commercially
available where individuals have
identified themselves by their expertise
and their location and so to the extent
that you have a problem that needs to be
solved a specific way it knows who's
physically the closest I've seen
actually people have built up and tested
prototypes where it knows how to
assemble a team of people that actually
know the right services but that's I
mean it's not the technology I think is
probably simpler to get to than some
kind of a sustainable business model
were you thinking about something
specific I was just interested in sort
of what the ramifications would be if
you're sort of randomly assembling a
group of people that specialize in a
particular area of the patient like what
the Team Dynamics would be like when you
do that's interesting question it's
probably a problem because it's not
really a team right I mean it has
because they've never worked together I
think that's actually a really fair
question probably a question that would
have an issue you know would have
implications there is a exact model of
that bitten is in search of a solution
and that's the classic malignant
diagnosis patient who who's problem will
be presented at the next tumor right
exactly and how to get for specialists
from different domains available at the
right time right it's hard enough to get
an appointment for most physicians that
you're put off by a month so to get an
appointment with four simultaneously
could be six months right that'd be said
that's why I've said you know in some
ways people there's not really been a
mystery about how certain collaboration
creates better quality care but the cost
of convening is so high because physical
proximity is the only way to collaborate
and the idea is that as collaboration
technologies begin to lower the cost of
convening
more people can benefit from
collaborative care is the basic concept
hi there my question is regarding the
decision support systems so want the
implications of implementing technology
is that you can access various
information from different sources at
the same time IBM is using Watson I'm
interested in knowing like what are the
other cheaper decision-making support
systems which can be used by me being on
demand healthcare systems or other
facilities which can't afford a what
what's interesting question because I
mean if you actually think about to be
the first primary objective for a Watson
is it's a super fast indexing lookup
tool right that's really you feed in all
the information and it has the ability
to retrieve it doesn't create snow
knowledge it's just a search tool and I
think I mean I I guess part of the
problem you often have is that the
nature of some of the questions can be
often answered but I think the
technology is moving along pretty
quickly oftentimes though the question
is do you need to look at all the data
in order to answer a question or just a
subset of data because the whole speed
and retrieval is somewhat related to
that and if you start out by sort of
saying that every question you have to
go through everything define you get one
set of activities but many times these
questions actually end up being answered
by a relatively consistent subset of
data which is why people start to try to
create smaller domains I don't know if
you guys have any thoughts on that
question about the speed of technology
right
part of the interesting question of
course is decision part of purpose for
decision support is to augment the
realities of human decision-making right
so it intentionally has to do things
that we typically try to take shortcuts
I mean our natural tendency is to make
pretty good decisions using shortcuts
but we also screw up so you have to
build this technology to sort of not
take the shortcuts in order to find some
of these things but
right
thank you